the inescapable conclusion that i came
to after re-watching steelers ravens
yeah let me hear this
how in the hell did the steelers win
that game right
right
it is it's kind of like when you watch
it back you just go wow
you know the ravens really outplayed the
steelers on both sides of the football
and i don't want to disrespect the
steelers in any way because you know
again part of their magic is we're big
we're ferocious we're fast on the
football field we hit hard and we force
bad things to happen certainly but the
ravens are the type of football team
that that that is that way too you know
and
uh
i i think you know the the way lamar
the offense moved the ball continually
through the day you went okay yeah
ravens you know the tur other than the
turnovers kind of won the match up in
the meat and potatoes part of the game
and then on the other side of the ball
too i mean hey
pittsburgh offense couldn't do jack
diddly squat until the third quarter i
mean they could not do anything there
was nothing in the first half and they
just hung in there and someone that's
this is why you signed players and have
big time playmakers on your football
team you know we talk about oh why can't
this team get over the hump or this team
close a game out or do that well you
know this is where players come through
and in big games you know the steelers
just got so many of those type of guys
that they made a lot of these type of
plays in the big moments and that's how
they won the football game mike but
you're right i mean when you sit there
and watch it you go
i don't know i mean if they play 10
times i think the ravens win their share
of them but we'll see where that goes
the next time they match up
the turning point in the game came
on the first snap from scrimmage for the
ravens in the second half 17-7 they held
the steelers the steelers punted lamar
jackson floats that ball
that i don't know what he was thinking
right right right it gets picked off by
high smith that sets up the short field
the steelers score two plays later they
go 21 yards it was a nice catch and run
by eric eber into the end zone
that makes it 17-14 that's the moment
the game changes and then the steelers
get the ball back and their longest
drive of the day was 57 yards that's it
right 57 yards they had 20 yards in
penalties to make it a 77 total yard
drive um and uh there was a there was a
what was it there was a 15-yard penalty
basement
yeah that's right
on the drive that was part of the game
you know that was part of the game mike
i'm glad you brought it up you know the
two long drives for the steelers and
yeah the drive you're talking about is
the one there they were down 17-14 and
they scored to make it 21-17
you know
the the one thing that i noticed in the
game at least watching it back is yes
okay here it is what jump-started the
steelers offense i can't say it was
anything schematically more than just
they finally just started to play
one-on-one ball hey
you over there get open against that guy
and big ben will throw it on the outside
corner and you catch it for six yards
hey you over there run a curl route big
ben will throw it to you we'll get eight
yards they kind of just started nickel
and diming them that way with one-on-one
matchups and then took a few shots
where they got past interference so yes
it's not going to look great on the
total yards you know for your offense
and things like that but there was
probably close to 70 or 80 yards and
pass interference calls on the ravens
and there is that shows you again the
value of hey you're going to play us
aggressive we got to take our shots not
just to back you off but because this
day and age in the nfl interference is a
big part of the game and that was smart
on big ben's you know his part too and i
wonder if baltimore will adjust next
time they play a little bit and it was
the drive to put the steelers ahead
21-17 they got 20 yards in field
position from a pass interference call
uh that that uh
with ray-ray mcleod right who was on the
field a lot running routes for the
steelers on sunday and then the face
mask came up on their final drive that
resulted in points when they went back
ahead
28-24
it was
45 yards that they gained the
old-fashioned way right 35 yards on the
drive came from penalties yeah and
that's the one that included the face
mask and fueled that drive to allow the
steelers to go ahead and then and then
to hold off the ravens but yeah when you
watch that game and you look at how the
ravens ran the ball they averaged 5.6
yards per carry they turned out 265
yards it just felt like a suffocation
but the steelers just kept hanging
around and and it never looked pretty
right and you know that
it was sputtering and the running game
you'd see a flash of james connor runs
for 18 and then they bottle him up and
the drive's over and uh but but but the
steelers just that that's the thing the
resilience and i think i really do
believe this
i think that last year's struggles
and their effort last year to hold it
together and not just fall apart when
roethlisberger was lost for the season
in week two and they had bad quarterback
play behind him i think that that fire
they went through week in and week out
and trying to win games and winning more
than they should have yeah i really do
think that that mentality has carried
over this year where they never give up
in any game and uh they got look they
they weren't they haven't been outplayed
like they were yesterday in a long time
or sunday rather than a long time and
they still got that win but it does set
the stage for a great game coming up
three weeks from thursday night on nbc
when the ravens go to pittsburgh what a
way to end thanksgiving oh my god
because the ravens are going to be
pissed off they're going to be salty and
uh
it's it's going to be great to see if
they can pull it off again what do the
ravens need to do though when you look
at the mistakes that were made well yeah
lamar jackson what do they need to do to
iron those out how did those happen yeah
well okay so let's let's break it down i
mean the first thing what do they need
to do to iron those out how did those
happen yeah well okay so let's let's
break it down i mean the first
interception i mean that's just that's
just bad football you know and lamar
just misread the field he kind of looks
left at a short route and he comes back
to the right side and without really
diagnosing where spallane the new middle
linebacker to come in for devin bush's
he kind of just turns and throws it
blind without kind of assessing what it
looks there i think he just thought wow
i've been looking left that surely moved
the coverage underneath that way there
should be a hole bam i'll hit it right
there he did a great job of kind of
staying there and he was kind of ready
to make the jump so hey you got to see
throws so that happens at times he made
a mistake now you know the other the
other turnover that's concerning is it's
7-7 another drive where baltimore just
goes right down the field on the
pittsburgh steelers and they had their
way like you said in the run game it
kind of started off early on with like
edge runs and oh man the steelers can't
get lamar on the edge and some of the
running backs and then they
overcompensated tried to stop the edge
runs and then baltimore was like okay
you're trying to stop the edge runs here
we're gonna smash it up your face now
and go right up the middle they really
had a good way about that but the game
is seven seven and then he holds the
ball way too long in the pocket i mean
that's the golden rule when you play
pittsburgh for really about the last 30
years you can't hold the ball too long
they're coming they got more big bad
mofos like we talked about yesterday
than just about any team on the planet
so
that is where you have to play them
differently than other teams your
interception to start the second half
you talked about mike the throw where he
tried to throw it over hi smith there's
there's a lot of issues there that's
spider 3 banana
hi smith somebody go back and watch the
play
he's
the the mark andrews does not run the
route deep enough one high smith is
covering ricard the fullback in the flat
yet he can cover both of them because
they're so close together he kind of
midpoints them and yeah lamar took a
chance and tried to get it in there and
didn't get it done you know obviously
but uh i you know i i think the big
thing is
mistakes for baltimore even the first
touchdown as patrick mcqueen eric ebron
wide open the shallow cross they they
they shot themselves in the foot
repetitively throughout the day in that
game you know but they're going to be
able to walk away and like we said in a
lot of ways they're going to feel like
man we screwed this up we could have
handled this game a whole lot different
and probably controlled it
uh and that's where it's going to be
interesting on thanksgiving night to see
how they bounce back from this
and that running game was so impressive
you know they're trying to force a
passing game into the mix they're trying
to make lamar jackson a drop back passer
to complement the skill set the
incredible skill set at running the
football and it makes sense you never
want to be one dimensional but when you
can gash a team for 265 yards and you're
doing it without mark ingram i mean
think about what mark ingram is feeling
after seeing the performance from gus
edwards and jk dobbins with ingram out
they're gonna come to the conclusion
they don't need ingram after this year
most likely with edwards and dobbins
right and uh and and and why would you
not do that again chris if they can't
stop it that's one thing the steelers
couldn't do on sunday is stop it
do you expect based on what you saw that
that's exactly what they're gonna do the
next time just keep running and force
them to stop it and just assume that the
fluky little things aren't going to
happen that give the steelers a chance
to win i think they're going to rely
more on the run game next game i do
because they're not going to trust lamar
jackson all the way and that's where the
interesting chess match goes because
this like we talked about a little like
this was pittsburgh's first real look at
like whoa lamar and the baltimore ravens
hitting on all cylinders type of offense
you know and they they struggled with it
they did there's no doubt you know like
i said they kind of you know started off
the game hitting them on edge runs and
then started working their way up the
middle there's just a lot to defend with
the run game in general you know because
they do such a great job of baltimore
moving people doing things creating more
gaps to cover on a certain run play to
where you go oh i think we have
everybody covered all the gaps covered
over here but now you know they do a
speed sweep and pull a guard and they
have a full back and all of a sudden
there's three more gaps to that side and
can you get over there and fill all
those gaps in time they really stress
you out that way so
that's where it'll be interesting and i
think pittsburgh will learn some things
about
you know how to play him
and how they want to play the game in
general next time around you know that
that that that'll be interesting to see
the other thing too mike that i think is
worth bringing up and why i think the
next time
to like what you're saying
why not just run it and keep running it
on the last drive of the the second to
last drive of the game right the drive
that ends up and lamar jackson running
the quarterback draw on fourth down and
he fumbles and mink fitzpatrick all that
that drive right there
baltimore ran the ball
every play
pittsburgh played
three down linemen and five linebackers
with only three dbs in the game the
whole drive
they basically were saying
please throw it baltimore look at these
great looks we're gonna throw and
they've played and baltimore still
didn't throw it they ran the ball and
they ran it successfully but i think
that'll just embolden them next time to
go run it
and i think it also says a lot about
pittsburgh
basically said
go ahead try to beat us with the pass
we're not going to let the run game beat
us we don't think you can beat us with
the pass now they were fortunate the run
game worked but i thought it showed
something on pittsburgh and then i
showed something on baltimore and the
fact that they just ran it even though
there was only three db's in the game
and there was all these guys at the line
of scrimmage to where they didn't even
want to flirt with that and lamar
jackson either i just to me that was a
little bit of a psychology analysis by
me but i think it says a lot but i think
it speaks to the reality that the ravens
and lamar jackson specifically
if they get a lead and if things start
going well early it snowballs right yes
it's like the game last year against the
dolphins when miami came out and said
we're not letting you run it beat us
over the top and lamar said okay i will
right and i think if you give the ravens
a look like that
right out of the gates they will throw
it but after there's been some mistakes
and maybe after
greg roman and
john harbaugh are thinking hmm
you know he's a little off today he's
made some mistakes we're not going to
take chances that maybe they'd be
willing to take right out of the gates
like they threw on the first drive and
it was a pick six even wasn't down the
field but still it was a pick six on the
third play from scrimmage so i think
you're right and
uh if they can't look that's the thing
if pittsburgh just can't stop the run it
doesn't matter how they configure the
defense the ravens just keep running a
game that's the safest way to chew up
the game score points and win um so
here's the problem though and this this
gets back to the spring of 2019
when the ravens are looking for
receivers and no free agents
want to sign yeah with the baltimore
ravens
and so what do you do you start drafting
guys like miles boykin and hollywood
brown
and now now look last year and it's
funny when you look at his numbers week
by week last year and this year
hollywood brown had a 100 yard game week
one each of his first two nfl seasons
and then after that the numbers
go down but if you're winning
who cares if you have minus two yards
receiving in a game if the team is
winning but if you've got three even if
that three yards was a touchdown and you
lose you go to twitter and that's what
he did what's the point of having
soldiers when you never use them and
then to emphasize the point in
parentheses with two exclamation points
never he deleted that tweet
but you know the point was made and uh
you never really can delete anything in
this day and age so let's hear from john
harbaugh yeah on hollywood brown showing
that frustration with his lack of
involvement in the offense on a day that
the team didn't win
i'll tell you this he did he did play
the game like a soldier
he was fighting
very hard out there
blocking and running routes and had
obviously big touchdown catch almost
another one right before that
so um you know i like the way he was
fighting i don't disagree with the fact
that if he's saying he's a soldier
but i promise you we're trying to use
all of our guys he knows that
probably a little frustrated but
uh he's not a selfish guy i don't
believe he is for one second
uh if he was he wouldn't play as hard as
he did or be the good guy that he is
around the building every single day so
i have a lot of trust in him um and the
fact that he took it down i appreciated
that
wow uh look
now it may have been a very different
conversation between john harbaugh and
hollywood brown behind the scenes
uh but but
the coach isn't going to throw gasoline
on the fire publicly he handled it the
way he had to but you know again anyone
wondering why they didn't sign antonio
brown
this is why you don't want to add
another guy to the mix who wants the
football for a team that from time to
time is just going to say screw it we're
going to run the ball yeah no doubt and
you know listen john harbaugh he
understands the kind of guys he's you
know recruited and signed there with the
baltimore ravens you know they're not a
bunch of boy scouts that's for sure so
he realizes that he's gonna have a few
guys pop off every now and then it's you
know that's the the risk they take of
having that kind of renegade tough guy
team mentality it's a little bit like
pittsburgh that way gonna have to deal
with personalities you know certainly
but you're right it's always going to be
an issue and i'll say this just as long
as you're running that offense it's
going to be an issue as far as receivers
are concerned and all that but they got
to find more of a specific role for
hollywood brown it's something i've
written in my notes for a few weeks
where i just go
you know the the lack of wide receiver
involvement in their offense is
concerning and again we're not holding
baltimore to like oh you know can they
beat the crappy teams in football i'm
talking about yeah they need to get them
involved if they want to win the super
bowl and beat the top teams in football
the chiefs the steelers those type of
teams and with hollywood brown he's not
a kind of guy where you can just go hey
we're going to line you up there and
we're just going to go one on ones all
day no he's not that way he's not big he
if he if he gets disrupted and jam
coverage off the line of scrimmage the
play is over that way but they need to
find more of the you know the same thing
we see with debo samuel and those type
of things speed sweeps all those type of
things more wide receiver screens
intended pure shots down the field just
for hollywood brad i do think it's an
element of their offense to where it'd
be nice way to get cheap completions for
lamar jackson another weapon to worry
about out on the edge with the baltimore
ravens and of course give some love to
the receivers that way it's it's one
area where i do sometimes look at them
and just go oh they need to find a way
to get him the ball more just because
he's too damn fast and not not touch it
enough times
hey one guy who jumped off the screen
last night re-watching the game was
willie snead ooh willie snead willie
snead made big catch after big catch
and uh really helped keep that offense
going when the passing game was
sputtering so you know hollywood brown
can't say we didn't throw well that's
what they say willie's needs a soldier
too so it was kind of disrespectful he
might but you're right you're right they
did throw i'm sorry i didn't mean to cut
you off there
no but but my point is they are capable
of throwing yeah some of those throws
from lamar jackson had that feel of
desperation
and it's like the ball just pops up and
a couple of times he found a guy down in
the middle of the field and just
happened to be a big hole there and
that's where the ball landed right so it
came down to that throw in the end zone
and snead yeah five catches 106 yards
right not a bad day for willie snead and
uh of 208 passing yards he had more than
half of them but the last play of the
game it was intended for snead mickey
fitzpatrick broke it up when you look at
that more carefully was someone else
maybe more open or was that just
destined to not work from 25 yards or so
out with time running out yeah just a
destiny too hard there that to me is you
know again a little bit of what we said
i don't think that changes from what we
said yesterday you got to scramble
around in those
instance and make a play why why you got
to scramble around because try to draw
one of the defensive backs towards you
right you got to find create some holes
because think it they had eight men in
coverage they know they don't have to
worry about getting beat behind them
right their eyes their body everything
is ready to i'm watching the quarterback
and we're ready to run forward and
attack right so within that it's very
hard to throw a ball in your normal oh
i'm gonna take a five step drop and hit
the ground and throw it like you
normally would in the in that moment
there
it's you'd have to have somebody wide
open to be able to fit that type of
throw you'd have a coverage bus it's
just too hard to wear yeah i would like
to see him go back there scramble around
buy time see if he can get some
secondary people to move and then you
throw some sort of laser into the end
zone you know i think those are the best
way that would be the one thing i would
have looked at mike um
you know and and it just it was tough
it's too tough to throw that ball with
that many people in coverage ready to
react
let's flip it back to the pittsburgh
offense for a second they go up seven
nothing on the pick six the ravens
outscore them the rest of the first half
17 nothing mike tomlin talked about
making halftime adjustments
was there anything you noticed again
they had tribes that didn't require them
to do a whole lot thanks to penalties in
short fields but did you notice anything
different in the offense and
specifically in the passing game when we
got into the second half no i i
definitely did you know and there's two
things to hit i want to hit on this here
with one with the pittsburgh but then
the other one the baltimore's defense
but yeah um
definitely you know in the first half
and this is one of the reasons i picked
the ravens to win the game
was
you know some of the
oh pick plays shallow cross picks wide
receiver screens type plays baltimore
was all over that they weren't gonna let
like that de facto steelers run game you
know you know wear them down with oh a
six yard screen here oh a four yard
short little pick play here oh you know
another shallow crossers picking each
other across the middle for seven yards
here they weren't going to let that
stuff beat them and then what ultimately
what i felt like pittsburgh did in the
second half to finally get rolling is
they more just what i wrote in my notes
they just played one on one ball hey
you're one-on-one out here hey claypool
run ten yards stop i'm going to throw it
on your chest hey you you're over here
it's one-on-one you know work them
outside i'll throw a slant in there they
kind of just said that it was like the
hell with the scheme hey they're in
man-to-man big ben oh i like this
matchup and he threw that and then there
was a few little short passes where they
caught them in zone and just a few
handful of plays but to me that's all it
came down to and that's all it needed to
happen and big ben you know as you
mentioned earlier he took some shots
that created some pass interference
there's some great value in that um but
that's really all i could come up with
mike that i saw that i felt like was the
big difference between first half and
second half steelers offense
and i look what the game needs no more
hype and we're not going out of our way
because it's an nbc game i can't wait
yeah for this rematch thanksgiving night
this is the ultimate gift from the nfl
for thanksgiving night to see this game
again the stakes will be as high as they
can be as we said last week if the
ravens hope to avoid the chiefs if they
hope to find a way to let someone else
go in there in the divisional round and
beat kansas city while the ravens are
waiting for whoever it may be to come to
them in the afc championship they got to
win the division yeah and if they lose
to the steelers in 23 nights
they are not going to win the division
barring a complete and total collapse by
pittsburgh it's too much ground to make
up so that game is going to be
gigantic all right mike one more thing
one more thing go ahead just on
baltimore's defense because this was a
big move last week and we really didn't
know it yannick and gawkway
that was it it's gonna work i mean just
from what i saw there
he popped a lot in the game and i really
think it's going to give baltimore more
versatility on defense the fact now that
they're going to just be able to rush
forward and be able to depend on that a
little bit to where to like you're
saying you get in the playoffs and they
got to go play patrick mahomes you know
where they've been burned those times
and those type of things is they gotta
blitz him and then we know what happens
there oh it's one on one or blitz he
makes you miss and all that this that
was a big move and it showed real
positive on sunday it did he was around
big ben a lot um so that'll be
interesting to watch going forward
he still isn't going to catch patrick
mahomes he's still not going to get
patrick holmes forget it it ain't going
to work if it gets down to that if it's
chiefs ravens in the postseason but but
that's a good point another thing we
haven't mentioned ronnie stanley out for
the year for the ravens missed most of
the game they still were able to run the
ball with his replacement but they need
to stay healthy because if guys start
going down and continue going down on
the offensive line it's going to be hard
to open those holes and it's going to be
hard for the ravens to keep running the
football
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports